[music]
there was a disaster of the pilots Serhiy
among them Andriy Beljekov with him something
Ukrainian an officer one of those who
helped our country a lot our
condolences to the relatives and friends of all who
knew the guys the
investigation of what happened was ongoing the
details are too early to say of course
everything will be clarified  circumstances, of course, Ukraine will
never forget everyone who protected
him, not
because he and his father had a
dream to come true,
pilots don't die, then they go into the sky,
and he must
wait for this plane. I want to stop all
Ukrainians
who have left friendship,
promise me that I
will make a circle in the first plane, definitely, definitely  as
soon as the plane
instead of him, well, he
was one of the first Ukrainian pilots
who went to the West, in particular, the United
States of America, to lobby for this issue of
providing f16 to Ukraine.
Western partners were afraid to
say something, to promise to transfer to us, well, certain
fears, how we will invest this weapon, whether
it will fall into the hands of the enemy,
but Jus actually led an approbation
meeting, that is, they checked
how good it is Volodya in English,
how well he has a good command of
technical material, I know the material
part  they say that the plane is composed of its
base according to the parameters of the ability
to navigate in difficult crisis
situations, well, that is, it is all
theoretically important work, which in one way or
another goes ahead against
Unfortunately, the number of deaths is already too
high, but every death is painful,
pain is felt, irreparable losses bloom
on this clay,
young,
talented  beautiful to live hurts too much
[music]